Jennifer Lopez recently paid tribute to
the queen of Tejano music Selina with
this beautiful video on her YouTube page
you know today marks the 25th
anniversary of Selena's tragic death and
I still believe to this day that that
movie was one of Jennifers greatest
performances but we met her long before
that when she was out trying to be one
of the flies women in the world went
from being a Fly Girl a short term bob
full eyebrows and slightly nervous that
was JLo when we first met her in 1990 21
years old auditioning to be a Fly Girl
on in living color fast forward six
years Jenny from the block had made the
transition from TV to movies
I don't always look this bad it's a lot
of makeup it's like you walk in the room
and they love you and that's it she's
the one no I have to read like 17 times
I have to bend over backwards hi
Entertainment Tonight I'm Jennifer Lopez
and you are on the set of Selena I'll be
playing JLo invited et cameras to join
her as she got ready for the big Selena
premiere my husband check out how
excited she was telling then husband Oh
Hani Noah about the rocks that she got
this is real baby metal put it down the
thumb game Mena real from behind the
scenes of her films to onset of her
music videos to red carpet fashion look
after look we've been there for all of
the most iconic moments of JLo's life
like this one
she's always been open hard-working and
focused and you know what we learned a
lot from Jennifer like when you fall
down you just got to get back up
remember this moment from the 2009 a mas
the furthest thing from my mind was that
I would slip
I'm literally if you if you slow motion
that thing I go for so much air I
thought I was Michael Jordan another
lesson age is definitely just a number
the 50 year old hustler proved she could
be an Oscar contender she learned how to
pole dance and put on a lights out
Super Bowl halftime show how did you get
through the rest of that performance
when your daughter came out there it was
a beautiful thing and so she and I were
just so happy doing it it wasn't like a
tearful thing it was a celebratory thing
during quarantine JLo and a rod have
been making family tic TOCs and staying
safe holed up in their Miami home no
doubt wedding planning has been put on
hold but JLo says there's no rush she's
found her soul mate I think we're very
alike in many ways and I think that's
what makes it work we're likely except I
can't saying dance
[Music]